sans surprise les autorités proruses
revenant donc revendique donc
aujourd'hui une victoire écrasante au
référendum d'annexion les responsables
des régions ukrainiennes de zaporigia
Carson luganz kedonies ont annoncé la
victoire des oui en faveur d'une
annexion par la Russie résultat vous le
voyez à la soviétique allant de 87 à
plus de 99 % par an noir on retrouve
tout de suite notre envoyé spécial
Gwendoline de Bono en direct de carquive
bonjour Gwendoline vous rentrez tout
juste de zapporodia c'est le jour
d'après dans ces quatre régions quel
climat qui règne mon Mons parle
oui et d'ailleurs ce jour d'après il va
et bien son nul doute se transformer en
une annexion à le Kremlin va d'ici à la
fin de la semaine probablement décidé
d'annexer ces quatre régions
ukrainiennes peu importe que le scrutin
soit illégitime peu importe qu'il soit
considéré comme tel par l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale et le jour
d'après et bien à zapporica ou je me
trouvais hier et bien c'est aussi ces
fils de voiture que l'on voit sortir des
territoires
occupés par la Russie au niveau du sol
checkpoint qui permet ce passage des
territoires
occupés par la Russie au territoire
contrôlé par les Ukrainiens à bord de
ces voitures on voit des familles qui
sont exténuées et on voit aussi des
hommes qui ont le sentiment d'avoir
échappé à un piège le piège de la
mobilisation parce que tous les hommes
hier à qui nous avons parlé nous l'ont
confirmer les autorités russes sont
passées un message très clair dans les
territoires occupés à savoir que les
hommes après et bien la fin du
référendum avant l'annexion par le
Kremlin et bien les hommes seront
désormais mobilisables devront
sans doute enrôler pour aller se battre
sur le front par ailleurs ces personnes
à nous ont décrit également une
situation économique extrêmement
difficile dans les territoires occupés
c'est également une des raisons de leur
départ d'autres nous ont dit que les
autorités russes avaient été également
très clair sur un autre point c'est
qu'après et bien ce référendum factice
des passeports rue seraient distribués
et il serait obligatoire de prendre ces
passeports russes alors qu'il y avait
ces alliés dénonce depuis une mascarade
promette une réponse forte volodime
zenenski a promis hier soir de ne pas
abandonner le bon basse sous-entendu il
va y avoir et postes militaire
alors en tout cas ce que l'on constate
au moment où je vous parle c'est que les
troubles ukrainiennes font des gains
territoriaux importants notamment dans
le Dombas c'est ça c'est très important
de le noter parce que le Dombasle la
reconquête totale du don Bast s'éteint
des buts de guerre
énoncé par le par le Kremlin et en ce
moment et bien les Ukrainiens
progressent notamment autour de la ville
de Limone qui est quasiment encerclé il
y a des assos sur plusieurs directions
et nous avons pu parler aujourd'hui avec
des officiers qui sont déployés sur
cette bataille et les gains sont assez
importants certains d'eux nous disent et
bien que les lignes russes pourraient se
disloquer également sur ce front assez
rapidement il faut comprendre que en ce
moment les troubles ukrainiennes d'abord
profitent de la contre-offensive
victorieuse dans la région de karky il
tire actuellement les fruits de cette
contre-offensive et ensuite ils sont
engagés dans une course de vitesse
d'abord pour gagner le maximum de
territoires avant les pluies d'automne
et ensuite gagner du territoire avant
que les hommes mobilisés par le krem on
arrive en nombre sur le fronton en
direct de car kiff pour France 24 Merci
à VOUS Gwendoline on